twitter を見ていて
私はふと思った
日
アイコン変えたいアイコン変えたいアイコン変えたバイク解体今回第今回 by 公開
twitter が行こうか痛いですはじめ社長ですツイッターのフォロワー様が
おかげさまで281万に行きましたありがとうございます
日本6位です前髪をすっごい短い時があったんですよほみたいにねアホみたいに前髪が
短い時があったんでその時外やすい
いって自分の変な場合髪をこうだとか払拭しようときゃわいいかなアニメない子でした
んですけども by 神結構伸びてきたでもアイコン変えちゃってもいいのかなと思い
まして twitter 内航変えようと思います
というジュースね企画や大事ですよもう僕が皆さんとコミュニケーションを取れる唯一
の手段とも言えますからできればこうかっこよくねもっとエレガントおしゃれてクール
なイケメンない
今にしたいけどそういうのといえば僕の選ぶじゃなくて皆さんが選んだ方がいいのが手
に入るんじゃないかなと思いまして今回ちょっと皆さんに僕の新しい何かを募集しよう
と思います例えば時刻が浅野さんず40分です
みんな起きてるかなぁあるしこれでいいでしょう吹いたない公開ます何か良いや以降
ありませんかね
じゃあこれで皆さんからどんな a子が来るがですねしばらく待ってみましょう
日常っていうアニメがあるんですけど僕する大好きでそこにいそうな顔をした僕っぽい
キャラクターアイコンですかわいいぜ気に入ってるんですけどやっぱね
実車の方が誰かというのはわかりやすいんでまぁ見ていきましょう
新倉丼
んみんなありがとうマシな奴じゃないぞ
ませんってがない人はまずフレア男 a gun とでクールな行こうね者がみんなな
んでご覧に走るの
ありがとうございましてありがたいありがたいんですけどこれだと決めやばいよ
ちょっと決まらないよ俺じゃないった罰金だよめちゃくちゃであっはぁっ
俺こんな顔したかったってこれは彼が側ですねガスツリーなぁ難しいなぁなかなか中で
が難しいですよねはいいコンって
なつかすぃなぁこれかおふざけたとしかないのかな
だいなまいこれだっていうアイコンがなかなかないですね
これねこれいいなこれこれでしようかな
でもこれだと何で僕腕を超すというか服も立ちたこれだと何で僕旅行してるかわかん
ないんでこれにしましたこれはもうちょっと突き出してなんかこの右腕がちょっと気に
食わないので右腕何か待たせたりこれをカスタマイズステイツ新しいアイコンにします
それにしますでも右腕が少し物足りないので何か持たせてくれる
戦艦たみなさんはこれに何を持たせてくれるのでしょうか
[音楽]
なーめんカーなんでよもういいですね全体的に俺じゃねえは全部とビックさんが大学生
の頃多いのでバスケットボールでいいですねラメ直径や杉田玄白の解体新書に怒られる
よね夢と希望を持ってる某 u 2
なぜ俺の顔またこれに戻したやめろ種を持ってるんだしでもしたらいい男
[音楽]
かかってんじゃねーか元気玉ですああああああまだ来ない
かっこいいこのちょっといいかもしれないですすげー強制的にもやしは載せたからか
そうですよねコーラ伸びるまでもうすぐなんですよ
野郎俺の中学の時誰が無駄あー購入のいいと思うんだかすごいこれしっくりきてると
思う
かっこいいっ
はあ
あざーずすぎてスキあ
よくこんな想い付け根にんじんごはんでデビューを作ってくれてますね
使いづらそうですね
[音楽]
キャッシュ等みたいになってるねではなんかよく見たらかっこよく見えてきたぞ
ような友情カードの融合みたいになってるなにこれ
うんにみんな大好き itunes card 確かに課金してさんが彼をしています
が
たく
親分ごめんねたったの出来心なんだけどすごい今日頭悪かった
がったへしてる桜あこれちょっと端これはに保存しておこう
めちゃくちゃ王者ロイが多いんですけど全然に権持ってるとかっこいいなぁこうライト
セーバーかいいねぇいい
太鼓なぜ自分の理由をされているかっこいいぞこれ
ちょっとかっこいい雷何かそれっぽい顔それからちょっと怖いは俺がなされた空間はな
枕を持っている
なんかほんとこれはは狂気を感じるねなんかアニメさん
アニメのキャッチみたいになってるあ
まぁそれっぽいけど施工いたが談合グっぽいとこで ppp やってるし皆さんセンス
がちょっとすばらしいですよ
おいしんではすごい想像力だねここまでくると力をためてる系ね
ありですこれもすごいいいとこれかわいいだ後紙ついているもいいっすよね
ありがとう懐かしいこれ昔おいだから作った皮を持ってるねー
ああ
もう常定やここまで来ると itunes でこの夜遅くで僕のしょうもないアイコン
の画像を作ってくださって本当に皆様ありがとうございます
全部紹介できなかったんですけどもかなりたくさんのアイコンが届きましたけど水から
僕のツイッターな以降はこちらになり今も知らなきゃちょっとしばらくはこのついて
ない金でやっていきたいと思いますまだひょっとして
twitter やってない人いるかもしれないんでこちら僕のツイッターでござい
ます自分でひょっとしたら僕とお話ができるかもしれないので良かったらみなさん
ツイッターの方も下ろしておいてください
これであった流出に行って買うんだけどどれだけだじゃじゃーん
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ